رواج سياحي شهدته مصر الاول مره منذ جائحه
كورونا
مشهد عاد لقلب الاهرامات وباقي المقاصد
السياحيه في مصر حيث شهد قطاع السياحه
رواجا منذ العام الماضي وخاصه النصف
الثاني وامتد لهذا العام حيث استقبلت مصر
نحو 12 مليون سائح وهو ما يماثل العدد قبل
عام 2020 اي قبل الجائحه كما ارتفعت نسبه
السياحه في الربع الاول من هذا العام بنحو
50% مقارنه بالعام الماضي
كبير قوي في عدد الجانب اللي دخلوا مصر
السنه دي تقريبا وصلنا ل 12 مليون فرد في
اي مدن زي القاهره الاقصر واسوان الاماكن
اللي فيها مشته لان طبعا ده بيرجع للمناخ
وحاجات كتير تانيه عده وعوامل ربما ساعدت
في عوده الحركه السياحيه منها الغاء قيود
السفر لدى الدول بسبب الفيروس وعوده
السياحه الروسيه خاصه الى مدن البحر
الاحمر وايضا اختيار مجله الدعم الامريكيه
ومحطه سي ان ان لمصر ضمن افضل الواجهات
السياحيه في العالم
لعده اسباب منها واحد ان احنا بقى عندنا
جزء قوي جدا مركز على هيئه تنشيط السياحه
وعلى اظهار مصر بشكل مختلف بانماط مختلفه
وده شاهدنا فيها سياحه المؤتمرات سياحه
المعارض شاهدنا سياحه الترويجيه لعروض
الازياء اللي حصلت في مصر شاهدنا السياحه
الكلاسيك بتاعتنا العاديه كان عندنا
بتاع العمله او انخفاض قيمه الجنيه مقابل
العملات في ادى ان بقت السياحه جاذبا
لقاعده عمله اكبر رغم ارتفاع الاسعار في
اوروبا
[موسيقى]
التفاعل على صفحات السياحه على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي على ما يبدو له اثر
كبير وخاصه على الشباب موضوع البلوجرز
بيساعد جدا في تنميه السياحه خاصه اللوك
الماركت والدوماستيك زي شرم الشيخ الغردقه
الجونه اماكن كتير قوي جوه مصر السياحه
تعتبر احد اهم مصادر الدخل القومي لمصر
كما انها مصدر الرزق الرئيسي لمدن مثل
الاقصر واسوان وشرم الشيخ والغردقه حيث
يعمل معظم سكان هذه المناطق في السياحه
سواء بشكل مباشر او غير مباشر سمر بشات
لصباح العربيه من القاهره
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات